I shall I shall not try to translate ah
but you've heard it all I suppose it it
seems so loving is it good or bad for a
relationship to have a fight from time
to time oh it's a must but it's but even
if it's everyday the question is not so
much the fighting the question is really
the repair I think relationships follow
a cycle of harmony disharmony and repair
sometimes they it seems that the people
they bring up the same old things when a
friend it's the same old topics yeah
when people fight about the same stuff
what they're fighting about is not the
towel or the bathroom ordered who takes
care of what or who takes the children
every day or who is always late what
they're fighting about are actually
three key groups of themes that are
underneath those plot lines which is
power and control closeness and care and
respect and recognition so do we tend to
fight early in the relationship or late
in the relationship when you when do we
tend to fight months
look some people come with a history
where they learned we learn to fight we
learn to argue we learn to defend
ourselves we learn certain ways for
asking for what we want or we learn
certain way never to ask for what we
want but to criticize the other for
doing it when you can't do it yourself
and we come with those schooling's of
our relationships that usually we
learned in our own homes by watching our
parents with each other and with us
some people are maximizers they explode
some people are minimizer's they implode
they keep it in they wait they wait they
wait and then they explode you know like
and over something that has nothing to
do with the thing they're actually
annoyed about but this is the right
moment yeah it's not always about words
it's it's an energy the more one person
goes up the more the very person that
goes up is actually made
the other person go numb and the more
the person door shuts down the more it
actually activates this one to go i RN i
each person is actually contributing to
the extreme version that the other
person become what about bickering
because you have couples that are sort
of bakery and just all the time is that
the same would you say the city coming I
would say bickering is chronic low
intensity warfare in which I am picking
and I'm critical all the time and
instead of saying I would like a cup of
water
I say why did you take a cup for
yourself and I am not telling you what I
wish because behind every criticism is a
wish and I'm just going at it and going
at it and making yourself you feel down
low contemptuous I also when I talk
about the cup I remind you of the shoes
and of the friend you didn't call back
and of what your mother told me 17 years
ago and I do what is called kitchen
sinking meaning I pile up all the dirty
dishes in the sink at the same time so
that at the end we have no idea what
we're actually fighting about it began
with the cup of water and it ended up
with the day that you broke up with me
when we were going on our first date
you know I see and when you start to
clean it's it's like a big job yes yes
you can't clean the dishes when you've
got all the dishes in the sink at the
same time so you do kitchen sinking you
do chronic picking the bickering you
also have two wonderful things one is
called confirmation bias which is that
now that I've decided that you really
are a slob and you don't care about
whatever I ask you I look for it I look
for it it's like a radar that is looking
to confirm the bias that I have if I
believe you don't care if I believe I
just doesn't matter
III scan it and I disregard evidence
that proves the opposite the one time
that and if you say but I did it yes
except that's just yesterday that's one
time that doesn't count because look
Tata Tata Tata and you know the whole
scoreboard arrives
and the next thing I do is what we call
fundamental attribution error which is
that if I am late is because there was
traffic
yeah if you are late is because you are
a total disorganized slob so it's about
my whole character yes - circumstance
yours is characterological I see cuz I
had a bad day if you're in a bad mood is
because you're a cranky human being they
recognize this so so Eric who are you in
a fight what would what would your wife
say she will say I'm stubborn and wrong
and wrong I'm wrong
yeah she's right and wrong yeah but you
don't give up at least I mean very much
taken by what we hear here I mean of
course the bigger the love the more
important the quarrel I mean a person
who just passing in this state cannot
harm you in any real way a colleague
which is distant can maybe harm a little
bit but not much
very close colleague or a close friend
can harm a lot and your partner cause
this is a person can harm me the most so
they're great to the low the more
important she knows the buttons she
knows every single weakness I've ever
displayed in my life I don't fight so
much but after this I'm gonna go home
and fight can I go now
I heard something in your podcast you
mentioned that that it's important to -
actually you don't have to give people
to agree with them but you have to give
them the sort of acknowledge that they
have they have the right to have that
opinion or they have that you have to
respect their opinion in a way so it's
kind of the question of can people fight
better right is there a way that that
you can minimize some of the escalation
basically a bad fight is a negative
escalation how do you turn and a
negative escalation follows a very
classic pattern attack blame defend how
do you turn that around so that people
can actually hear each other because
behind anger there is often hurt behind
criticism there is something you want to
there's an unmet longing and we shall
need etc and one of the first thing is
this thing about not being right is can
you imagine that there is this person
that is so close to you that actually
has a completely different experience of
what just happened and that's very
challenging we in a relationship because
if I feel this way you must have done
this otherwise why am i feeling it it
cannot be that I feel so neglected and
that you that you think you were being
really warned for example right and so
the next thing that is of course the
most difficult thing to do is to talk
about what you feel versus talk about
what the other person did or did not do
you know it's a way of saying I can hear
you and still disagree with you versus
if I hear you then it means that I agree
with you and when you are in conflict
situations we have the ability to listen
to 10 seconds and 10 seconds is three
sentences before in our head with
stopped listening and we are preparing
the rebuttal so it's very short how much
people can actually stay in a
conversation when the when the tension
is mounting and what you want is to turn
it around so that people don't feel
attacked they can pay attention they can
you know turn it into a little bit of
you know from from conflict or to our
empathy if you want and then validate it
and still say you know I don't think
I've done this but I can see that that's
how you would experience it that's how
you would see that's how you feel
that kind of thing and that that
fundamental shift into a from a negative
escalation to a reflective listening
from reacting to reflecting is really
where you turn the whole thing around do
you have a difference between the sexes
here do you have a do the women and men
fight differently look there's a lot of
studies that have checked on the
sympathetic and parasympathetic nervous
system in men in situations of stress
and if we are in an intense intense
conversation and fight it is often so
that the men will look up that a man
will move their bodies that they will
try to regulate themselves to lower
their physiological reaction by trying
to create some space from the heat
whereas women can stay in there much
longer without necessarily diss
regulating to the same extent besides
that I actually think that what I just
described I can see between two men
between two women between a man and a
woman I see it in families I think it is
more a temperament and we are born with
the temperament be what was reinforced
in our growing up see what the culture
tells us you know it is definitely a man
who's angry is a man who's in charge a
woman who's angry is hysterical let's be
very clear that the cultural valence on
on on assertiveness or aggression is not
the same for men and women all over the
world so there is layers of different
things but I don't think these things
are intrinsic to gender what is a good
way to end the fight there's different
things you know what I don't think at
this moment I'm doing justice to this
conversation
I'm gonna go cool off and we'll come
back one
[Music]
that's a ground that's you know as in
you know what I get so angry in those
situations let me go and just chill for
a second because otherwise I'm gonna
regret what I'm gonna say and I don't
want to do that and then you need to not
follow me around the house you need to
let me go and trust that I will come
back the person who leaves has the right
to go but they have to be the one to
come back to you know what apology is
really important when I did this
yesterday I was out of line I was angry
I wanted to shoot I wanted to hurt I
felt attacked and I really regret this
and I'm really sorry that goes a long
way to three letter writing I've done a
lot of letter writing with people
because when you're alone and when you
sit with yourself and you write to
someone and when I receive it and I read
it you hear two people completely
differently so sometimes it's go and
just say when I thought yesterday it
brought back something for me that has
nothing to do with you actually it
brought back the time when I felt that I
was always being kicked by my brother
and that I had no place in this house
and you just made me feel small like
that and I got in touch with that and
when that beast hits me I am ready to
kill and I just wanted you to know that
that's you know variations of letter
writing with accountability what is
accountability it's your ability to take
responsibility for what you did without
being mired by shame responsibility is a
relational conscience so is guilt shame
is I feel so bad that I want to go hide
and I don't want to talk about it and so
the next day we pretend like nothing
happened but it's it's there you know I
just don't want you to remind me you
know how bad I feel about myself not
about what I did to you and that's the
thing in a fight is that people often
feel terrible about themselves
afterwards they don't like it they don't
like what comes out of them they don't
like how they behave they don't like the
face that they can have even if it's a
quiet face you know a seedings face
three days three days I walk around like
this
you know and let's you know and and and
and make you plead with me and but all
kinds of dances like that and when you
can just say you know I don't like this
about me so why is that so crucial
because what is the fundamental
definition of self-esteem it's your
ability to see yourself as a flawed
person and still hold yourself in high
regard as their I know that that you
your your choice of profession has to do
with your parents is inspired by your
parents life tell me about that hmm
I mean I think you know some my parents
were both concentration camp survivors
of the German Nazi camps they both are
the sole survivors of their entire
family they both were about five years
in the war and then another five years
illegal refugees in Belgium so that's
that's where they met no they met on the
lib on the road the day of liberation as
they came out of their own respective
camps that were close by and I think you
know from very young I would ask
questions why don't I have grandparents
where is everybody why do we have such a
small family how come you have an accent
and then as you grow and they tell you
the story then you see what made you
want to stay alive what makes somebody
want to stay alive five years as you
live face to face with death you know
what did you do when other people gave
up what is the difference between not
being dead and being alive which is
really the foundational question that I
work on with couples it's not just to be
surviving but what does it mean take to
be thriving and so I think a certain
interest in the human condition in the
in the limits of what we can tolerate in
what it means to fall in love in the
concentration camp for my dad like how
could you still in the midst of this
humanize yourself and experience
feelings that normally you're not meant
to feel when you treated like animals
and
from there you know why do I have the
nightmares what does it mean to have
this kind of legacy and and I just
became really fascinated by what gives
us meaning did I fight my parents my
father adored my mother and felt like
she had the founder the the woman that
he would never have married if there
wasn't the war because they would never
have met and my mother definitely was a
much more explosive reactive person and
he had a way of just kind of taking
disappearing and then she would you know
definitely amplify and he would minimize
and she would rise more and then he had
a way of just going and giving her a
kiss and saying is this worth it is this
worth it after all what we've gone
through is this worth it and just I had
an amazing way to pacify her or to shut
her up whichever way you're going to
look at him but it was effective it's
like you know he he just kind of would
say keep it in perspective
after all this we're gonna fight over
that now what does that do to a child it
makes every problem feel rather
insignificant you feel like you can't
really what wonderful final word thank
you so much as deeply hope you enjoyed
the clip for more interesting
conversations please hit subscribe